このいろいろ超能力者言うことはまあ聞く
聞く瞬間にはなるほどと
僕は笑っちゃいますけど
今宜保さんが消えたんですかね
やっぱり嘘ってあんまり長持ちしないんですね
でも平気であれぐらい嘘言う勇気も勇気なんですね
大したもんです 人間っていうのはそういうふうに
いかにバカにさせても
もう次にまたまた騙される
そこがまた面白いんですね
一人に二人に 三人に 四人に騙されちゃったらもう十分でしょうに
それでも気をつけない
また次の超能力者が現れてるんだから
その人にもまた信頼する
それその人インチキだからまた年で消えると
じゃあ次の超能力者ましょう
いい加減やめればいいのに
まあとにかく 大変苦しみだけある次元がありますということだけここで言えるんですけどね
それ以上は無理 そう 今まで説明したのは
人間の立場から見て それより低い次元の話
それつあるんだけど 一応アパーエ・ブーミと言うんです
皆様方 アパーエ・ブーミという言葉だけ覚えていればいいのです
ニッバンメヴァ・カーマ・スガティ・ブーミ
カーマ・スガティ・ブーミっていうのはかなり大きな世界なんです
それはまあ 人間もそこに入っちゃうんです
こちらには人間の世界と神々の世界入るんです
人間と神々は一つの次元にいるんだと
人間の世界はいくらかわかるでしょうと思いますけど
神々は六段階に分けてね
六天と言うんですね つあります
で そこはまあ 人間の世界ではまあ楽しみがあって
苦しみもそこそこにあるんですけど
まあそれほど苦しみはないんです
人間の世界で まあそれほど苦しみがないんです
で 一応人間の生きる衝動っていうのは楽しみを探すことなんですね
戦うこと 苦しみを探すことは衝動になってない
病気な人は別として いわゆる精神的な病気の人は苦しみを探してますけど
一般的な人間というのは楽しみたいという気持ちがあって
それで活動してるんです
それで楽しみたいなという気持ちがあるんだから生きてるんです
幸せになりたいなという気持ちがあるんだから
人間が仕事をしたり 結婚したり
子供育てたり いろんなことをやってるんです
ありとあらゆる苦しみをやってるのは楽しみたいだからなんです
ですから 楽しみたいということで生きてるんです
そういうことでスガティといい生まれだと言ってるんです
天になっちゃったら もっとレベルが高いんですね
もう徹底的に楽しむんですね
で 楽しむしか道がないんです
仕事しなくてもいいんです
子育てしなくてもいいんです
神々にも子供がいるという話があるんです
そこで神々にどうやって子供があるんですかと
そしたらまあ神々は妊娠したりはしないんだと
それ苦しみだから ですから
化粧 化粧というかね 突然現れるんですね
そこであるところにある神が
神が一人か二人かいる
一人いるところに突然もう一人神が現れちゃうんだと
現れたら その前にいた神が
あなた私の息子だ娘だとすぐ愛情を作っちゃうんだと
そこで二人で親子みたいな感じで仲良くするんだと
そういう風にこの何かいいところだけ取ってるんですね
で まあ大体人間から見ても
やっぱりね 私の子供だ
私の娘だと思うのはすごい気持ちいい感覚なんですね
自分の実の息子でなくても
娘でなくても 他の人みたいな
なんとなく娘みたいだなと感じたら
なんとなくすごい気持ちいいものなんです
で それだけいいとこだけ取って
何のご飯あげなくてもいいし
向こうもまたそれなりに一人前の神だから
で 面倒見なくてもいいし
ただ二人で仲良く楽しくすればいいんですね
で そういうふうな子供ですよと
神にいる子供は まあ神々の場合は次元もありますから
この一番下の次元というのは仏教用語で四天王と言うんですね
種類的神々があって 全く性格も体の形も違う種類がいるんですね
で それはまあ四天と言ってますね
その上にヤーマという天国があって
それからターワティンサという次元があって
それよりトゥシタというところがあって
その上にニンマーナ・ラティがありまして
パラニンミタ・ワサワッティという番目があるんです
番目のパラニンミタ・ワサワッティっていうのは
ものすごい力強い神々なんです
ニンマーナ・ラティというのは番目なんですけど
創作 自分でいろんな楽しみを創作して考えて楽しめるという
もうかなり天才的なんですね
決まってるパターンではなくて
下の次元では決まってる自分の次元に決められて楽しみを味わってるだけなんですが
この番目の神々っていうのはそういうふうなことじゃなくて
それぞれみんな能力を持っていて
自分の能力を使って楽しむと
という意味の言葉なんです
実際はわかりません で
番目の神々っていうのは
このパラニンミタ・ワサワッティという
このこのいろんな下の次元の神々は創作して色々楽しむんだけど
それは自分で奪って楽しむんだと
自分でやらない すごい力を持っていて
自分がそれを支配している
で まあたとえで言えばわかると思いますけど
ミツバチが一生懸命自分が美味しく食べるためにハチミツを作るんですね
そういった 人間がそれいて取って美味しく食べる
人間がハチミツはすごい美味しいですよ
で これは何とか何とか
花のハチミツはもっと美味しいですよとかね
いろいろ考えてそれ取ったり食べたりするんだけど
自分では一滴も作ることはできないんです
どんなにもう全然もう科学でいろんなもの作るでしょ
じゃあハチミツも合成してみたらできないでしょうね
あれはやっぱりミツバチが作らなくちゃいけないんですね
ミツバチのね 唾液で作るものだから
で それ楽しく人間が偉そうに食べてるんですね
だから まあミツバチみたいな感じなんでしょうかなと思いますけど
この五番目の神様はいろんな楽しみのものを作ったりするんだけど
六番目の神様はそれを支配している
で それで六番目の五番目の神様が苦しんでいるかというと
別にそうじゃないんです
彼らにはまた新しいものを作ればいいし
作ることで楽しんでるんだから
これ誰かが処分してこなきゃ困るでしょうし
ですから 人間の社会を見ても
いろんなものを作る 作るのは楽しみな人々いるでしょうに
作って作って 自分の家であっちこっち積み重ねる
何の楽しみもなくなっちゃうんです
それで何か作れば誰かが来て
あれこれすごくいいものだから私にちょうだいと言って持っていっちゃうとすごい楽しいんです
で また作るんです 新しいもの
で また他の人が来て それまた持っていっちゃうし
いわゆるお金がある人はその人にお金を払ってそれを持っていく
ですから お金ある人はやっぱりレベルが高いんですね
でも自分では何も作れないんです
ものを作る人はすごい上手で
いろんなものを作るんですけど
やっぱり誰かそれを持っていかないと自分の楽しみも消えちゃうんです
ですから 互いに大変いい関係できているんです
それで六番目と五番目の神々の関係なんですけど
この真ん中にいる神 四番目の神様も別に誰ともあんまり関係ないんですね
ただ自分で努力して楽しむんですけど
ある程度レベルは下なんですけど
菩薩なんか生まれるのはそちらなんです
我々のお釈迦様も人間に生まれる前にこの兜率という天国にいたんだそうですね
そちらから人間の母親のお腹に入ったと
で 今も今もいるんですね
お釈迦様の母親が向こうで
で もうそういう話を作ってるのは
おそらくこの まあいろいろ信仰している人々のためだと思いますけど
今でも浄土仏教であんまりこの母親を拝むとかね
それはあんまりないんですけど
キリスト教ではあるんだけどね
メアリーを信仰することはね
仏教でもなんとなく考え方は一応置いとくんですけど
発展してないんです だからまあ僕は合理的に考えると
人間がそんなに神々にお願いしたければ
神々から助けてほしければ
仏教徒の人々もなんか助けが必要な時があるし
で それだったら自分たち仏教徒だから
お釈迦様の母親がね いまだにあの育った母親が涅槃に解脱しましたから
もう涅槃なんですね ホジャーブティボーって
産んだ母親はマヤ夫人で
まだいまだに天国にいるんです
で 今男性ですけど で でもそこにいるんです
で いるんだから まあなんとかお願いしますと言ったら
私の息子のお弟子たちだから
まあいくらかなんとかやってあげようと思う可能性はあるんだけど
どうも誰もやらないんですね
それ失礼だなと思いますけど
スリランカの人々もミャンマーの人々もどんな神様を拝んでるかというと
ヒンドゥー教の神様を拝んでるんです
それお釈迦様にさんざんいじめられた連中だから
何もやってくれない可能性あるんですけど
そこでアナータピンディカというね
祇園精舎作ったと まだ天国にいるし
で ウィサーカ夫人もいるし
結構いるんです 兜率天国には仏教
ほとんど仏教の人々の方が多いみたいです
他の天国ではそんなないんです
仏教の人々は 少ない ですから
兜率次元はまあ結構仏教の人々いるみたいですけど
もうどうも誰も全然気にしないんですね
これ仏典はね そういうのは別に証拠もない
単なる人間の信仰の世界なんで
それでもその中でも人間っていうのは非合理的に見るんだからと
僕はその中で合理的に見るんだったら
神々を拝みたいければ
まあ兜率天国にいるもうお釈迦様の一番近い弟子たちがいるんだから
まあどうせ仏教っていうのは兄弟宗教だから助けてくれるはずなんです
仏教徒というのは互いによくもう面倒見るし
それは当たり前のことになってるんです
全然ご褒美とかもう何も気にしない
例えば人が瞑想するんだったら
誰かがそれご飯やら必要なものを何のことなく用意してあげるんだから
だから私にご褒美しなさいとかね
褒めなさい それはないんです
そういうすごいこの あの
なんか兄弟みたいな世界なんですね
お釈迦様の道っていうのは
それだったらたとえ神であろうとも助けてくれますけども
ヒンドゥー教の神々がスリランカにいらっしゃる時は見てください
いろんなところに で 仲良く仏教をやってます
ヒンドゥー教と一緒に
ヒンドゥー教の人もお寺に来るということは全然違和感も何もないし
だって自分の神々もいるし
仏教の人々もヒンドゥー寺院に行くということは何のこともなく
やたらと行っちゃうんですね
実際状態はそういう状態なんですけど
仏教の人々はタミル人のヒンドゥー教の人々を大変やっつけている
殺していると嘘ばっかり宣伝していますけど
一人も仏教の人はタミル人を殺してないんです
タミル人が仏教の人々を殺してるんだけど
そちらにあるのは違う宗教なんです
その人々はそういう話を流しちゃって
仏教を何とか壊そうと
だからあれはタミル人に対するタミル人が喧嘩しているというよりは
この国から仏教を追い出そうという活動なんです
もし仏教が消えちゃったら
タミル人が今まで一緒に仲良くしていたんだから問題なかったし
今も一緒にいるんだから
ある地方の人々だけなんです
ずっと全国どこにでもタミル人はいるんです
シンハラ人の村の真ん中見去っても
もう一人二人何のことなく商売やっているんです
そういう人々もお寺にも行くわ
お寺ともすごい仲良くしてる
もう何問題ないんですからね
そちらにあるのはこの国から仏教を破滅しようという運動なんです
ある人が論文を書いて
なぜアジアで南アジア歴史的は失敗しましたかという論文が書いてあったんですね
だから今度こそでもやるそうと
まあそれは自分の国では言ってはいけない発言であります
神々の世界っていうのは
まあどんな宗教にもあって
まあそういう仏教にもあって
神々次元があると 仏教でそういう
例えば他の宗教からヒンドゥー教から神々の概念借りたにしたっても
ヒンドゥー教ではその六天の考え方はないんです
ただ 神々ということはあるんだけど
はっきりしないんですね
これこれまであるっていうことも
梵天という概念もあるんだけど
どれぐらいあるか どれぐらいあるかとか計算して数えて寿命書いてとか
そこまではないんです
で まあ仏教でここで言っているのは
人間の次元と神々の次元は同じということなんです
人間よりはるかに違う超次元の存在とは言ってないこと
ですから カーマ・スガティ・ローピという次元に神々も人間も一つに入れてるんです
そこで楽しみの多い順に順番を決めてるんです
この神々と人間の次元に比べれば
人間は大変楽しみが少ないんです
苦労してやっと楽しめる
上々行けば行けば大変楽です
六番目いえばもう何のことなく他の人々の幸福を貰って楽をしているんだからね
じゃあちょうど説明しなくちゃいけないのはこのルーパ・アヴァチレ・ブミという三番目なんです
ルーパ・アヴァチレ・ブミっていうのは色界地なんですね
色界地の違うところは
この瞑想 瞑想しなきゃそこは行けないところ
天国は徳を積んだら行けるんです
いわゆる特別超能力的なものなくても
普通の人間で道徳をやれば天国には行けるんです
ただ 人間の心の中で幸福になりたいと
悪くはなりたくないという気持ちは必要なんですね
堕落はしたくないんだと
立派に生きていきたいんだと
そういうこの明るい思考があって
明るいことを目指して生きているんだと
たとえ貧しくても立派な人間で生活するぞと
そういう風な気持ちで生活して生きていれば
もう天国には行けるんです
そんなに行くとこ難しいとこじゃないんです
生まれるのは難しいのは人間なんです
人間の世界 地獄にも行くのはすごい簡単なんです
動物の世界に行くのも簡単なんです
それが合理的な考え方なんですね
で 制限ないんですね 動物の世界
我々知ってるのは実況の動物だけなんですけど
いくらでも生まれるんです
いわゆる支え どうしようかと
そんなたくさん生まれたらどうしようかという問題はない
生まれる たくさん生まれて困ったらそれで苦しめばいいと
それだけのことです で
餓鬼道やら地獄やら そういうところでは
この人が産むということじゃない
その人の悪いカルマによって
そこで体は形成しちゃうんですね
ですから 経済的な問題にならないんですね
自分自分のカルマで生まれるんだから
その分苦しまれるんです
天国も同じことで 化生だから
突然カルマの自分のいいカルマの力で
そこで体が出来上がっちゃう
ですから 他の神々は人口が増えて大変だとかね
もう食べ物がなくなったとか
いるところなくなったということはありえないんです
自分まあどれぐらい去っても何の関係もなく
もう大丈夫だ ですから
生まれ変わる場合は 地獄やら餓鬼道やら
あすらやらしくせやら
そういうところに生まれやすいし
天国もまた生まれやすいところです
人間が明るい思考を持っていいことをしていけば
もう何のことなく天国に生まれると
そこはもう人口多いんだから
もう今 birth controlなんて言いますか
日本語で 今やってるよとは言わないんですね
そんなできません 誰にでも
自動的に生まれるんだから
人間の世界はそうじゃないんです
資源がもう決まっているし
生まれたら育てなくちゃいけないし
ですから 人間の世界にいる人々にとって
新しい人が来るということは
もういろいろ自分たちがまあ貢献しなくちゃいけないし
その分犠牲とは言いませんだけど
まあわかりやすいけど
お金はかかるんですと
ですから 人間がコントロールしている
鍵かけているんです 来るなと
それもすごい悪い行為なんですけど
他の人はこっち来るなっていうのはすごいケチな行動であって
罪なんですけど そこら辺
まあどうまああんまり仏教は言わない世界でも
言ったって本当にくだらない
例えば宗教を持ってバースコントロールするなとイスラム教なんか言ってるでしょうに
それにまた他の人々は散々悪口言ったりいろいろこと言ったり
仏教はそんなことはあんまりもう気にしない
僕はいつでもこの中道っていうのは不思議な立場取ってるんです
やられないんです 誰 どんな人の考え方が出てきたってね
でも中絶はすごい断るんですね
それは人殺しですよ で
中絶は断ってるんだけど
バースコントロールするなとは言ってないんですね
で その代わりにちゃんと自分のところに生まれたくて
子供をちゃんと育てて財産をあげなさいと
そういう責任感があるんだから
一生懸命自分が責任感あって子供作るんだったら
もう十人二十人四十年も産まようとはしないでしょうに
自然にそれは自然コントロールになってしまうし
ですから仏教はそこら辺そこで置いておいてあるんですね
人間が経済だけ中心に考えちゃいますから
この鍵かけてるんですね
生まれることに そこで鍵かけてない国々にまで文句言っちゃうんですね
お前らボートコントロール
バースコントロールしなさいとかね
で すごいことをやってるんですけど
残酷なことまで で まあ理由はどうであろうか
客観的に見るとわかることは
人間で生まれることは難しいということなんです
それだけは徹底的に仏教で言ってるんです
どこに生まれ変わったっても
人間に生まれ変わることだけはすごい難しい
別に人間こそはすごい最頂点の天国っていうわけじゃないんです
でも生まれにくいところ
ですから このほんの瞬間だけ人間になったんだから
そのチャンスだけは逃すな
そのチャンスはもう二度と来るかないかわからない
だから私の足が悪いとか
腰が悪いとかね 家におばあちゃんが病気だからああだこうだとか
そんなことを言って その大事なチャンスを逃してはいけないと
だから何回でも生まれ変わることはね
いくらでも生まれ変わることを可能であるならば
じゃあ次にやります 今日はまあ今回はばあちゃんの面倒見ますけど
次回はまあ心育てることをやってみますというふうには言えますけど
次回またばあちゃんがいるんだからね
ということで 人間にはこの必死
必死になりなさいと というメッセージは言ってるんです
天界はまたすごい生まれやすいところで
色界はもうまた決してバースコントロールのところじゃないんだけど
瞑想して禅定を作ってないと生まれないんですね
その次元だけ特別な超越した次元なんです
世間ではない で あの第一禅定から第五禅定まで我々アビダンマの説明しましたから
その第五禅定あるいは経典で言えば四禅定なんですね
一から四まで その禅定を作った人々がこの色界に
で 色界という言葉はなぜ作っているかというと
この瞑想をするために色を使うんですね
色っていうのは物質の何か対象を作って
それで瞑想するんですね
ですから この自分がこの色に頼って
物質の働きに頼って心を調伏したんです
で はしごを持って上に登ったと
あるいはこの竹棒を持って高跳びする何かスポーツあるでしょ
すごい高く飛ぶんですね
やっぱり何かあのポールというポールですか
ロッドなければ飛べないんですね
そういう風にこの色を使って瞑想して
物質的な瞑想対象を作って
それに集中して瞑想して
心の次元を飛び出してもらうと
そういうことで その梵天に色界と呼ぶんです
そこで第一禅定 禅定を作った人々に梵天が三つ待ってるんです
それはブラフマ・プローヒタ
ブラフマ・パーリサッジャ
マハブラフマ 第一禅定を作った人々が
そのブラフマ・プローヒタ
ブラフマ・パーリサッジャ
マハブラフマというあの三つの国がありまして
そこどこかで生まれるんです
もしかすると三つの国というよりは
同じ国で同じ梵天という国で
このランクかもしれません
ブラフマ・プローヒタっていうのは梵天なんですけど
ブラフマ・パーリサッジャ
日本語で何でしたっけ
まあ梵衆天 で 梵天の住民という意味なんですね
いわゆる普通に瞑想して
すごいこの瞑想の達人というよりは
まあなんとか頑張って頑張って瞑想して第一禅定を得たんだと
得て それで気を付けて
まあ異形身で梵天に生まれ変わると
そうすると梵天の国民権はもらうんです
で ブラフマ・プローヒタというのは番目なんですけど
梵？え？梵浦天 浦ってどういう意味ですか
で あれは大臣クラスなんですね
いわゆる梵天で もうちょっとレベル高く
いろいろまあ他の人々の面倒を見たり
活動したり もういろんなことをできるレベルに生まれるんですね
三番目はマハブラフマ
大梵天 このマハブラフマっていうのは
このヒンドゥー教で言っている神様なんです
その次元なんです この大梵天にかなり強力な神々がいるんです
このプラジャーパティという梵天がいて
プラジャーパティという梵天というのは
このヴェーダ聖典で出てくるんです
神 人間と宇宙は全部創造して支配している
あの生命の主 生命の父という意味でプラジャーパティと言うんですね
その梵天がそこに住んでいるんです
また 他の神々もいるんです
あの瞑想して禅定なんか作って
かなり高いレベルで瞑想すると
この禅定は同じかもしれませんだけど
瞑想自体の達人にならなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば第一禅定にやっと入ったわけではなくて
もうすごく軽く時間かけて瞑想に入って禅定に入っていられるという
すごい身についた状態にならないとマハブラフマに生まれないんです
この前説明しましたから
この五慈再ってありますから
その五慈再という訓練をやったらもう達人なんです
この自分得た瞑想 サマーディの
サマーディの達人になったら
マハブラフマという大梵天に行っちゃうんです
で 達人になると そういう人々の次元と
またいくらかの精神的なコンタクトもできるんです
[沈黙]それは一応第一禅定の次元
次にはこのやっぱり次からある世界はこのあまりインドの宗教とは関係ないと思います
それはまあ仏教で考え出した言葉と思います
第二禅定を作ったらパリッターバ
アッパマーナーバ アーバサラという三つの梵天があるんです
アーバっていうのは光ですね
パリッタっていうのは少ないという
だから少光天 無量光天
発光天 だからどういう次元かっていうのは全然わからないんですけど
で 体というものはあるんだけど
どうせ私たちとは似ている体ではないんだけど
まあアーバっていうなんか光だけなんですね
光だけのいわゆる光子だけでできている体なんですね
素粒子で 光子だけの素粒子で体ができていて
その光子自体もレベルアップしちゃうと
さらにきめ細かくなっちゃうとアッパマーナバ
アーバサラとなるんですね
アーバサラって発光天と書いてますけど
その意味もはっきりしないんです
光発光する意味か アーバとサラと
サラっていうのは音ですね
光と音の次元かどうか
どっちかわからない まあある振動の次元なんですね
別に我々みたいにもう固体的な体あるというではなくて
ある振動だけの次元 振動するためには素粒子が必要なんですね
だから体があるというんです
それは第二禅定 で 第三禅定の人々はパリッタスバ
アッパマーナスバ スバキンハ
スバキンハかとも言うんですけど
で これは日本訳は少浄光天
無量浄光天で浄光と書いてますが
それまた訳はちょっとわからない
スバっていうのはもう光よりも何か高い次元の波動なんですけど
ことはないでしょうね
それだったら 光子のレベルよりも高いレベルのことを言ってるんです
浄 まあ清らかということで
光清らかとここで書いてるだけなんですけど
だから もっときめ細かい
あの波動の次元なんです
すばっていうのは まあすばっていうのは良いという幸福という意味なんですね
ですから まあなんとなく幸福みたいな波動でしょうね
そういう波動でできているんです
そこでそれは小さいかほどほどか
たくさんあるかというふうに三つの次元があるんです
その三つの次元はこの自分が得た禅定をどれぐらい訓練しているかということによります
そこで第四禅定の場合はちょっと難しい
第四禅定だけ作っちゃうと
このウェーハッパラという点
梵天に生まれるんです
ウェーハッパラっていうのは
まあまあ言葉通りに効果点ですね
もうもう最高な結果が得られる次元ということですから
いわゆる物質はそれ以上は成長しない
成長するかいうか それ以上は細かくはならない
光も超えてるし だからもう光の波動もないんですね
宇宙の根源的な時の波動みたいなものなんです
例えばビッグバンなんか起こる前にとか
ビッグクランチなんか起こる前にとかね
まあそういう時も何か宇宙のエネルギーに満ちてますから
もう何もないところから宇宙が出ますから
何もないところでも何かすごい波動があるんですね
その基本的な波動でいると寿命が長いです
土でできちゃったらすぐ壊れるんだけど
光できたらそんな簡単に壊れませんし
そういう宇宙の波動から見れば
宇宙の基本的な宇宙が現れる前のレベルの波動でできちゃったら
もう宇宙が消えたっても
その波動には全然影響ないんですね
ですから この宇宙はこの何回転もサイクルしたっても
その人々は死なないんです
そこに長い時間いるんです
寿命は後から出ますけどね
どれぐらい寿命は長いかと
今はこのウェーハッパラという梵天に第四禅定の人々が生まれる
それで仏教でやってはいけないと言っている瞑想がありまして
この物質を嫌うと じゃなくて心を嫌う瞑想
問題作るのは心の波動だと
心は嫌ですよというふうなことで
気持ちで瞑想しちゃったら
心のエネルギーは止まるんです
心のエネルギーは止まっちゃって
波動だけ残っちゃう 波動は物質の波動だけ
その次元がアサンニャ・サットと言うんです
いわゆる心がなく物質だけあると
物質といっても この素粒子もっと素粒子よりレベル高い物質なんです
物質だけあって そうするともうものすごい長い時間
その物質は変化しながらそこでいて
やがて心の波動が生まれると
生まれると死ぬんです
その世界は仏教ではやってはいけないと
行ってはいけないところ
地獄にも行ってはいけないと言うんだけど
まあこちらほどは否定していないんです
落ちるものは落ちるんだと地獄には
で このアサンニャという梵天にだけは生まれないようにというふうに気をつけているんです
だから一旦心止まってストップさせて
物質の波動だけであって
それからまたそこに心が戻るということは何の意味もないんです
で これ人間の例で言えばわかると思いますけど
例えば人意識がなくなったと
意識がなくなって 1時間経ったところで意識が戻ったと
そうすると あの 1時間はその人にとっては何ですかね
何も役に立たない時間でしょうね
それはありがたいと思って年がら年中意識不明になったりしちゃうと
もう何の得もないんですね
やっぱり心が機能した方がいいんです
たとえ体がボロボロになっても
心が明確に起動機能した方がいいんですね
そういうことで この意識不明の梵天には生まれ生まれるなと
意識不明状態なんです
そこでここで死んじゃった瞬間で意識不明状態になる
それでその代わりにある物質的な波動が出ていけちゃう
物質の波動があって それをずっと宇宙のサイコロギバーの八万四千界ぐらいいてから
それでまた意識が戻る
戻ったらそれでその生命も終わっちゃうんで
終わっちゃうのは他のところに生まれ変わらなくちゃいけない
そこに行くなって言ってるんです
それから悟った人々が預流果
一来果 不還果という 3つの悟りの段階がございまして
その瞑想するんだから
特に仏教の初期仏教の場合はサマーディ瞑想というヨーガ的な瞑想をまず先にやって
それから心の訓練はしっかり身について
煩悩をいくらか